geologists warned that Hawaii's Kilauea
Volcano might be primed for explosive
new eruptions our David beg no got a
view from a helicopter above one of the
craters yesterday huge rocks from recent
eruptions were scattered hundreds of
yards away aerial video also shows lava
coming from the most active fissure
David is in Pahoa Hawaii David good
morning good morning that roar coming
from behind me is one of the 21 fissures
that has opened up here on the Island of
Hawaii because of the gas we are wearing
these gas masks the National Guard
actually brought us to this location
this is what it looks like on the ground
we also went to see it from the air that
view above Kilauea spoo oo crater is
nothing short of spectacular and
sobering she was formed after one of
Kilauea z-- most violent explosions back
in 1959 and it looks vastly different
than it did two weeks ago according to
our veteran helicopter tour pilot Sean
Reger used to be flat up here with two
craters we flew about 50 miles to the
area above Leilani estates which looked
like this before the fissure eruptions
and now it looks like this
scientists say Kilauea is declining lava
levels helped contribute to several more
earthquakes Wednesday including one
measuring for point for those in turn
caused cracking on highway 11 that's a
main artery on the south side of the
island that cuts right through volcanoes
national park if that road would get cut
off there'd be some hardships for some
people the governor's told his National
Guard to be on standby to do search and
rescues if it were to come to that back
here in Leilani Estates as we watched
this incredible fissure blow you gotta
wonder how much longer this is going to
last in the mid-1950s there was another
lava flow and that lasted 88 days nor
wow that's some perspective David beg no
they're in Hawaii thank you glad he's
wearing that mask
just goes to show you the fumes are also
the gases rather are dangerous